we've been doing several videos now to
establish a bunch of truths of definite
integrals of various combinations of of
trigonometric functions so that we will
have a really strong mathematical basis
for actually finding the fourier
coefficients and i think we only have
one more video to go in the last video
we said hey if you take any combinations
of sines where m and n are integers that
either don't equal each other or don't
equal the negative each other then
you're going to get that integral is
going to be equal to 0 and then if they
did equal to each other well it's just
going to be the same thing as sine
squared of some multiple of t and that
that actually over the interval from 0
to 2 pi is going to be equal to pi and
just to be clear i wasn't as clear as i
should have been in the last video this
is going to be true where m is a
non-zero integer if m was zero then the
inside of this integral would just would
just simplify to zero and then the
integral would be zero so m has to be a
non-zero
integer for this right over here to be
true now what we want to do in this
video is conti is do the same thing we
did in the last video but now do it for
cosines that the product of two cosines
where m and n are different integers or
they're not the negative of each other
that that's going to be zero but if they
are the same integer and they are not
zero so that will boil down to cosine
squared of m t that that is going to be
equal this definite integral is going to
be equal to pi and we're going to do it
the same way that we did it with the
signs we are going to use some of our
trigonometric
some of our trigonometric identities and
so let's rewrite
let's rewrite this right over here what
we're trying to take the integral of and
so
this is going to be
the integral from 0 to 2 pi so cosine mt
times cosine n t
using a product to some trig identity
and if this is unfamiliar you can review
it on khan academy that is going to be
one half
times
cosine of the difference of mt minus nt
so i could write that as m minus n t
m minus n
t
plus
cosine
plus cosine of m t plus n t which i
could write as
m
plus n
t dt
d
dt
so let's think about two situations
let's think about the first situation
when and let me do that dt in blue
so dt
so
when actually let me let me now use some
integration properties to expand this
out a little bit this is going to be
equal to
so i'm going to write this as two
different integrals
so one integral from 0 to 2 pi
and i'm going to put the dt right over
here and then have another integral from
0 to 2 pi
and i'm going to throw that
dt out here
and so just using some integration
properties going to be one half
times this integral of
cosine of
m minus n
t dt
and then plus i'm just distributing the
one half and using some integration
properties one half and now this
integral is going to be cosine of m plus
n m
plus n t
dt
now let's think about it
when
m and n are integers that don't equal
each other don't equal their negatives
so let's think about m
not equaling n
or
m
not equaling negative n and we're always
assuming that these things are going to
be integers
m and n
well in that situation
this right over here is going to be a
non-zero integer and this right over
here is going to be a non-zero integer
and we've already established
we've already established that if you
have a non-zero coefficient here that
this definite integral is going to be
equal to zero the definite integral from
zero to two pi of cosine of some
non-zero integer times t dt well that's
exactly
that's exactly what both of these
integrals are this is the integral from
zero to two pi of cosine times some
non-zero integer t or non-zero integer
times t dt so in this case where m and n
are integers that don't equal each other
don't equal the negatives of each other
both of these integrals are going to be
zero and then you're going to multiply
that times one-half one-half times zero
zero one-half times or zero it's all
going to end up being zero so that
should
so that should hopefully make you pretty
feel pretty good about the case this
first case
and now let's think about the second
case where m is a non-zero integer we
could say where m is equal to n so in
that situation n and m are the same and
they are not equal to zero so let's just
take that situation especially because
when we're looking at fourier
coefficients we care about the
non-negative coefficients at least the
way that we've defined it so let's just
assume that m is equal to n and that
there and that m is not equal to zero
well and that would just resolve
that would take this integral and turn
it into that integral
well in that situation what's going to
happen
well this first integral right over here
if m is equal to n and m is not equal to
0 what's going to be m minus m you're
going to get this is going to be 0 t so
this whole thing is going to simplify to
1.
and then this right over here going to
have m plus m that's going to simplify
to 2
m
and so let's rewrite the integrals here
this is going to be equal to one-half
times the definite integral
from zero
to two pi
zero to two pi of one times
i'll write that one here one
dt
one dt
plus one half
plus
one half
that's a new color times the integral
from zero to two pi
of
cosine
that's let me do it in that same
of cosine
of
mt
dt
2 mt
d
d t
so once again we're assuming m is not
equal to zero this is the definite
integral from zero to two pi of cosine
times some non-zero
coefficient times t well once again
we've established multiple times that
this is going to be zero so this whole
second term is going to be zero and this
first one is going to be equal to let's
go to neutral color it's going to be one
half
times the antiderivative of one well
that's just t
evaluated from 0 to 2 pi
so that's going to be equal to 1 half
times 2 pi minus 0
2 pi
minus 0 well that's just one half times
2 pi which is equal to pi and so we have
now established this one as well and now
we have a full toolkit we now have a
full toolkit for evaluating the fourier
coefficients which we will now do in the
next video which is very exciting